when he was 22 chris trousdale was made
a criminal
he'd taken over the family shop and post
office counter
but the books kept showing losses he
couldn't explain
the post office accused him of fraud and
said if he didn't plead guilty
he could go to jail we can breathe a bit
now start to heal and
and rebuild today more than a decade
later his criminal conviction
and that of five other subpostmasters
has been overturned
a lot of us were told that we were the
only ones with this problem the post
office that was a standard line
and when we started to meet people who
are in the same position as us
it all became a little bit clearer and
we suddenly realized that this was
a very very big scandal the problem was
really this
horizon a post office software that
would show money missing when it wasn't
it meant hundreds of subpostmasters were
accused of things like fraud or
theft when they'd done nothing wrong
today
the post office said post office did not
oppose these appeals
and sincerely apologizes for historical
failings
we have taken determined action to
address the past
ensuring there is redress for those
affected and to prevent such events
ever happening again but seema mizra is
still waiting to know if her conviction
will be overturned
she was falsely accused of stealing 75
000
pounds from her post office and jailed
for 15 months
at the time she was pregnant i can feel
i can understand what they
what sort of feelings they must be going
through we've been fighting for such a
long time nearly 11 years in my case so
many people 19 years 16 years
it's so devastating what made me wonder
you know
post office had all the power to
overturn this conviction
ages ago even now as well they could
have overturned it
but they refused so
hundreds of innocent people have lived
with a criminal record
because of an i.t glitch it's taken
years to get to this point
where finally some are starting to see
justice done
catherine of totsi sky news